تحتاج القوات العسكرية المنخرطة في هذه المهمة
إلى معرفة ما يفعله القادة المحليون
على الأرض. يحتاج القادة المحليون
في هذه الحالة من قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
إلى معرفة
مواقفهم وما
سيفعله الناس ومدى السيطرة  إنهم
يتدربون على شعبهم وما
إذا كان بإمكانهم الثقة بهم بدرجة
كافية أم لا ليقولوا في الأساس المرور من
مجمع السفارة إلى المطار إلى
نقطة الانطلاق، الأشخاص
على الأرض الذين يقومون بذلك، عملاء
المخابرات
العملياتيون  يحتاج كل هؤلاء
الأشخاص إلى العمل معًا وأعتقد
أنك تعلم في الأساس اتخاذ قرار بشأن
ما إذا كان هؤلاء الأشخاص
جديرين بالثقة أم لا وما إذا كان بإمكانهم
الاعتماد فعليًا على ضمانهم
للمرور الآمن أم لا، لذلك في هذه الحالة نجح الأمر،
وكانوا كذلك  قادر كما تعلم جعل
هذه الفصائل المتحاربة أه تسمح لهم
أه بإخراج الأمريكان أه من
مجمع السفارة وهذا بالطبع
جزء مهم جدا جدا من هذا أه
تعلم ربما قدموا بعض الوعود
للمستقبل وربما فعلوا بعض
أشياء أخرى ولكن مهما فعلوا فمن
الواضح أنها عملت بشكل جيد للغاية